AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
STREET TOUGH.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
TODAY IS SESAME STREET DAY, THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE SHOW THAT
TEACHES KIDS IMPORTANT STUFF
LIKE "THE ALPHABET" AND "HOW TO
LIVE IN YOUR OWN TRASH."
"SESAME STREET" CHURNED OUT A
LOT OF CLASSIC KIDS TUNES OVER
THE YEARS, MOST OF THEM STUCK IN
MY HEAD.
MAYBE I STILL WATCH IT EVERY
ONCE IN A WHILE.
BUT MAYBE NONE MORE ICONIC
THAN KERMIT THE FROG'S "IT'S NOT
EASY BEING GREEN."
YA, THAT'S HOW YOU [BEEP] ROCK A
KERMIT.
NOWADAYS, THOUGH, IT ACTUALLY
SEEMS REAL EASY BEING GREEN.
I MEAN, KERMIT'S GOT AN ABC
SITCOM AND THINGS ARE GOING
GREAT WITH MISS PIGGY...AT
LEAST, ACCORDING TO THIS
PAINTING WE FOUND ON ETSY:
LOOK EVERYTHING IS GREAT.
THAT'LL DO, PIG.
THAT'LL DO.
COMEDIANS, LET'S REVISE THIS
CLASSIC KIDS SONG AND TELL ME
WHAT ELSE IT'S NOT EASY BEING.
>> NOT EASY BEING NAMED DONKEY
HAMMER.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
EUGENE.
>> IT'S NOT EASY BEING AN
ANTHROPOMORPHIZED PIG WITH A
UNUSUALLY LARGE SEXUAL APPETITE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
PHIL.
>> IT'S NOT EASY BEING DYSLEXIC
AND CANADIAN.
I'M A DOUBLE THREAT AND
INTIMIDATING.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
EUGENE.
>> IT'S NOT EASY BEING THE
BRUISED TIP OF JUSTIN BIEBER'S
PENIS.
>> CHRIS: WHY IS IT BRUISED?
>> ASK THE DETECTIVES FROM THE
70S.
>> CHRIS: EUGENE.
>> IT'S NOT EASY BEING A SUICIDE
BOMBER WHO GOT THE WRONG
ADDRESS.
>> CHRIS: YES.
>> IT'S NOT EASY BEING TOO LEGIT
WHEN YOU ACTUALLY DO WANT TO
QUIT.